the family of a man killed in a
suspected DUI crash last month is
speaking out tonight police say that
Lenny corello was hit and killed near
Gowen and Decatur and that the other
driver involved was under the influence
and speeding Sasha Loftus joins us now
with the story you'll only see on eight
news now
[Music]
listen away from his house
driver and died on impact her family
understandably is devastated and she
wants to see more done to prevent more
crashes like this he loved everybody he
loved life Felicity Carter remembers
what she loved about her uncle Lenny
carella those memories like all of us
are so grateful that we had those last
happy moments the 71 year old suddenly
lost his life in September when police
say he was hit by an impaired driver
down the street from his home near
Decatur and Gowen this didn't just
impact one person this impact several
lives
so far this year 45 people have been
killed in DUI crashes in metro police
jurisdiction we need director penalties
for driving Under the Influence retired
Nevada State Police Captain Scott Martin
believes a solution starts with stricter
penalties for first-time offenders he
also says enforcement is key to catch
those under the influence before someone
gets hurt what it comes down to is the
lack of resources and the lack of police
officers that are out on the road
Felicity tells me her family isn't just
grieving they're also angry if you're
caught drinking and driving there needs
to be bigger consequences and she hopes
sharing Lenny's story will help others
understand what it means when the worst
happens it makes you wonder why the good
ones are always taken first felicity's
family has started a GoFundMe to help
with Lenny's funeral expenses now the
man accused of hitting him 20-year-old
Corey Clark was arrested on a felony
charge of reckless driving resulting in
death and substantial bodily harm Sasha
Loftus 8 News Now